i'm very very lucky that i get to help
other people be the best version of
themselves sir david browsford to many
he's one of the greatest winners of our
generation if you can get a little bit
of insight why do i feel how i'm feeling
why do i respond like i do and then you
realize think wow a lot of my behavior a
lot of my life was driven by emotion it
wasn't driven by the real me
the best thing ever if it happened and
if it doesn't then you might be
absolutely devastated but you've got to
leave it as a dream then you've got to
understand that actually worrying about
the consequence of an event is
detrimental to the process and the
performance and the the chances of you
achieving that event
perfection perfection was so far away
that there's no point because we're
going to fail every day so i thought
well let's have a little progression
it's right then what could we do by next
week that we're not doing this week what
little things could we do there's a
million things that could impact
performance and it and it works it works
100 percent it works been 20 years
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast thank you so much sir david
brailsford
i've tried since this podcast began to
get sir david brasford to come here and
have a conversation with me so having
this conversation today and being able
to share it with you is one of the
highlights all time in this podcast
history
i don't think it's an understatement to
say that he has worked miracles with
teams taking teams in cycling that were
under achieving and making them
undeniably the greatest team in their
world and maybe of a generation
he's famous for this concept of marginal
gains it's a concept which i speak to my
team about every single day and maybe
that's why
i wanted to sit here with him
today you will understand without a
shadow of a doubt how to build a
successful team that's what you'll come
away with you'll understand how to be
successful personally you'll understand
how to inspire those around you to be
successful
but the surprising thing which i think
you'll also take away from this
is the cost of success
and we don't often take enough time to
ask ourselves that very honest question
is the climb worth the view
but by the end of this podcast
i think you'll be closer in your life to
having an answer for that question
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the director ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
a conscious sense of outsiderness from a
very early age
um you said that once upon a time and it
rang very um true to me as well and i
found it to be a very relatable thing
where did that come from where did your
conscious sense of outsideness come from
uh it's funny when you say that because
it resonates it really does so i was
very young just been born and my parents
my dad really decided to move from derby
where i was born
to north wales and and buy a house in
snowdonia very keen climber and he
wanted to go to the proximity of the
mountains so we moved over there and i
grew up it was a very very welsh uh
dominated welsh-speaking
little village called daniellen i went
to primary school there and grew up
speaking first language well sure my
friends are welch everybody was welcome
pretty much apart from my parents
and and i had this such a conundrum then
i didn't probably realize it at a time
but certainly on reflection you look
back
and you know i was very very much in
this welsh community very very tight
community
and and i'd go home and my parents were
obviously english parents and and
i felt you know my dad didn't really
conform he was there to climb he was
there's one of these outsiders would
come in there to you know
get up into the mountains and um and i
think that that left me
challenged i think because i was so
wanted to be
the same as all my mates same as
everybody else partly try part of the
gang
and yet somewhere inside i felt maybe i
wasn't quite
you know it wasn't i wasn't fully
immersed in it you know it wasn't quite
there and don't get me wrong i i loved
it and i still
i go back then i love it
you know my great friends there my mum
still lives there but i never actually
quite quite got that full sense of i
belong there you know so i always felt
that a little bit
on the outside i guess
you
went on to be a great anomaly in what
you've achieved in your life and success
and i look i always i'm always i'm i
guess i'm a bit noisy but and i did a
little bit childhood psychology when i
was in school so i try and look at like
which
what the parental dynamics were that
might have made someone that little bit
more relentless and that little bit more
hard working and i sat here with eddie
hearn and i go oh your dad i could tell
the way his dad was that ruthless
intensity clearly rubbed off on him at a
young age and i was reading about how
you described your dad and it seemed to
be
dare i say a little bit similar to
yeah he was often very when he was very
young so he lost his mum when he was
five lost his dad when he was seven
and uh of course for anybody that's
gonna have a big big impact and i think
he had a
you know life-changing impact on him and
um i think he
he was then fostered and um
you know he tells the story when he was
he was growing up in a foster family
foster family to eat together and they'd
make him eat in another room
and you know no
it was tough enough i guess
and i think that's had a profound effect
on who he was and
and he became somebody who was very much
uh you know driven to to make his own
way
and i think
you know that was um one of his core
core sort of deep seated drives and
values is that he
he pushed hard and he was always about
being professionals all about working
hard make your own way
you know don't rely on anybody else to
do anything for you do it for yourself
and um and he drilled that into us and i
think we just lived it really and
cycling i you were very into cycling
from a young age i had used to
wait on thursdays for this sort of
cycling newspaper to arrive yeah that's
psychic weekly yeah
yeah little magazine which is a bit of a
cult magazine you know quite a niche
magazine and i used to arrive get
delivered on a thursday
and i'd wait with great anticipation and
and you know it was one of those when
the
the newspapers came round you get your
cycling weekly and then you'd sit there
and read about all the results and who
done what and because there's nothing on
internet there was no there's no there's
no other way of getting the news you
know and
you know in the back there was all these
little sections where all the results
were all the race results
and he looked to see who'd done what and
study all his
he was like a real
you know it's a real
part of the cycling culture and still is
to be fair cycle weekly still going
despite all of the changes in sort of
media and everything else but so for me
it's a real cornerstone of my
growing up with the sport that's for
sure you you then go to school you go to
universe do you go to university did you
no no i didn't enjoy school at all did
an apprenticeship no no no well no i
left school on 16. yeah first i could
leave school i was out i was done yeah i
didn't enjoy school
why
no i just i didn't like being confined i
didn't like i'm just sitting chemistry
lessons and
no i just didn't it wasn't for me you
know i just didn't enjoy it and it
wasn't i couldn't do it so i don't think
i just didn't enjoy the environment i
enjoyed the the pe and i enjoyed being
with my friends and all that kind of
stuff but i didn't
i don't know i just didn't enjoy that
educational i felt trapped i felt
enclosed and um
and i don't know i didn't i wasn't
really motivated to
to learn at that time you know i was off
doing other things really do you think
because you had so much freedom in your
in your childhood home you then
struggled going to places where you
didn't have that same level of freedom
yeah well i certainly like autonomy
there's no doubt about that you know and
i think he's probably there since
childhood you know because i did i did i
enjoyed quite a lot of
freedom going up but i think it's quite
interesting because somewhere in the
back of my mind i knew at some point i
was going to have to go and you know i'd
have to get and
learn or yeah i felt this kind of
responsibility for an education
somewhere but i just wasn't ready you
know and um
and so i thought there was the uh
there's what i should do and what i
wanted to do i think and there's a
little bit what i should do
kind of came along and then in the end i
sort of thought well actually i
i want some freedom i want to explore i
want to go on an adventure or i want to
do something different and so yeah
so many of the guests that sit here
including jimmy cars very reminded me of
him have that moment usually in their
early 20s where they as you've perfectly
described it there's the thing they
should do usually what their parents
want them to do what society's told them
to do and what they want to do and in
jimmy's case it was like quit everything
and go and be a comedian put getting
paid no money because yeah yeah that's
what he wanted to do and take all those
unpaid gigs for you
you set off on a bike yeah to france
yeah yeah yeah breaking out of wales
moment right yeah and i kind of got this
um
it didn't happen overnight but slowly
but surely i started to really really
get passionate about cycling like really
the sport of cycling kind of it had the
freedom maybe
but it was a sport of suffering it was a
sport of sacrifice it was it was a tough
sport and i liked that
and i liked the idea that you were
it was only you you know this
if you could you know it's like the head
and heart really if you if you're
intelligent and and and you could
figure out how to train and then you had
the heart and the commitment and the
desire of passion to suffer a little bit
and how deep could he go and you know
that attracted me to cycling so if you
were good you were good and if you
weren't good you weren't good and then
uh you played a lot of football and in
all the little all the junior teams and
everything else you were growing up and
there you could you could have a great
game and lose or you could be
you know terrible and win the team could
win and i kind of like the
you know this idea that if what you do
really counted in terms of your own
performance as it were that sort of
chime to me anyway i kind of got this
passion for
the tour of france and this sort of
thing that was kind of happening
somewhere in the world and
the more i looked at it it felt quite
quite
gladiatorial and the mountains and the
you know it felt just epic a three-week
race and
all i wanted to do is go and see if i
could watch this race
and i got a chance to go and i stood
there and i got this passion for it and
in the end i thought right i want to go
and try and win nothing and so i sort of
said to my uh mum that right i'm gonna
i'm just gonna jack everything in and
i'm gonna go and
go to france and and see if i can become
a professional cyclist
and uh she was most of all horrified
actually i can't you know what you're
thinking
all this kind of stuff and i said to my
dad i said listen i'm going to jack it
all then i'm going to go anywhere yes i
really loved it yeah that's all i needed
to hear you know once i heard that then
i was like right it's okay i'm going
and so i got a single ticket to uh
grenoble
and got my bike in a cardboard box
rucksack
700 quid and
got a ticket going to banger station in
north wales and off i went i don't think
i'd ever really kind of that's across
remember went across london on the tube
with my bike in a box and looks like
that was a real ordeal for me
got down to dover
crossed on a ferry got to calais and now
sitting there and somebody came along
said you know you want a coffee or
whatever or drinking um you know on the
train and it kind of dawned on me then
so
yes
i've got a clue what's going on here
i was trying to find out i wanted to go
to a place called argentia that was my
destination and um i didn't know there
was two and so there's two argentines
turns out so i went i was trying to ask
this guy and um
to to buy a ticket to ajantia and he was
he's just been awkward
you know he could see i couldn't speak
french and obviously he wasn't making
much of an effort either and then these
two quite young guys came along and they
said oh can we help you you know we
speak french and and english and yeah
thanks so they helped out it turned out
they were polish and they were two likes
trying to defect from poland because
we're still communist and they were
trying to get into university in in
grenoble
and so the very first night i had in
france we slept head to toe sleeping
bags on this thing and these two poets
like they were petrified
so these any kind of steps or something
coming footsteps they'd jump and bumps
up rising like [ __ ] we're gonna get
caught
anyway so i jumped on the train six
o'clock in the morning jumped on the
train to where i thought i was going i
actually ended up in switzerland
yeah i was like whoa by which time the
fun had worn off
so i got to train the same time back to
grenoble again spent my second night on
the same platform the same bench
and then eventually the next day got to
where i wanted to go in uh john's yeah
i was a bit of an ordeal but why were
you why were you going there anyway what
was that what was the aim of when you
arrived at that destination what would
you say i wanted to be a i wanted to be
a professional cyclist you know i wanted
to find a way of getting into a
professional cycling team and you know i
think
there's no how do you do that you know i
mean back in the day when cycling was
very much a niche
sport in in britain there wasn't any
obvious kind of route so the club
structure
the amateur club structure
um in france was very very strong and
and they were like feeder teams sort of
professional teams
so if you get over there and get
yourself in an amateur team and if you
any any good you'd work your way up you
know so i thought right that's what i'm
gonna do did you have a meeting arranged
with an amateur team no no no so you
just showed up so i just went yeah and
then i um so i looked for the end of a
i looked for went to the end of a race
waited until everybody arrived
and you know finished the race and
they're all there's a car didn't have
the buses back in those days so the cars
were there and they came and so i looked
around and chose the nicest kits as you
would
seem like a good start
and uh i went up to them and asked if i
could race and they kind of what they
were like
and um
kind of chuckled and they thought it was
a bit hard and then he sort of passed me
on to the next team and then next team
and the next team and eventually
i spoke to one like a little group and a
guy came over and he said oh look we're
um he spoke english and he said we're
from centetchien
and if you can get yourself over to set
you up and we train his whole team
together on wednesday
he wrote me down the address and said
right coming at nine o'clock on a
wednesday and come train with us
so i started training with them and and
that was it i lived there for three
years then three years and eventually
you know you admit that you realized at
some point you weren't going to make it
yeah you weren't going to win
oh
yeah
yeah
yeah that was a shame but then i look
back on it now and i think if i don't
know now what no you know people say
what would you change you know if i
could go back in time i think if i knew
what i know now in terms of training and
nutrition and everything else i'm you
know i'm pretty sure i could have done
a much better job but i decided for some
bizarre reason i decided i didn't want
to
particularly didn't want to really
reduce my fat intake and just just eat
carbohydrate hardly any protein and so i
stopped um i stopped eating meat i
became you know vegetarian
and then i realized now i just nailed
all the time so i never really
optimized the chance that i had
which kind of makes me think now when i
get younger
you know young
talented or athletes or people want to
try it out and
you can't just leave them alone you know
just talent alone not always going to
get you there is it you know and they
need you need to be in the right
environment same as medication
when i was young growing up i'm i'm you
know i'm a bright enough guy i think
um i just wasn't ready to learn i wasn't
in the right environment to learn i
could have learned but i didn't learn at
the time and i i kind of reflect quite a
lot on that really now
in terms of creating the right
environment but to people
to be able to just progress you know
what's it take for a human being to
progress
and you know
i think my role is to try and create
those environments and support people to
do that really and i think i take a lot
of learnings from that you know
i want to want to
get to some of those key learnings that
you've had um
to to
take a step forward in your story you
then often go to university which is
actually quite surprising you do a
sports science degree for a couple of
years yeah it was early years of sport
science it was kind of developing you
know
and the idea of sports nutrition was
developing the idea of sports psychology
was just developing and i started to
read around this i thought god i love
this stuff i absolutely i couldn't get
enough i couldn't get enough so the idea
of eventually when i realized i wasn't
going to be good enough to you know make
the make the top end of professional
cycling i thought right well i'll go
back now because i will really want to
learn
and so i went back to university and i
was just absolutely wasn't interested in
anything to do with like freshers week
or going out i just wanted to learn and
that was it
so i met every every one of the
lecturers asked if i could have a
meeting and said i want to tell me how
you're going to teach me i want to make
sure that i learn as much as possible
how are you going to do that
and of course i've gone back since and
then
yeah a bit full-on you're into when i
first
and um and so i came out of that
and i i loved i absolutely loved every
minute of being at university i loved it
i loved meeting other people i love
people that got the same passion
it was a topic that i just couldn't get
enough of i loved the psychology and the
sports psychology and and i came out of
all of that and really wanted to go and
sort of pursue the sports psychology
area but it just felt at the time it was
too fluffy it was
you know the top pro teams weren't
really it's too like all too macho to
talk about you know psychology and so he
wasn't getting any traction at times i
thought god i'm not sure if i could make
a career out of this
so i ended up like i worked a bit longer
in um
i went back in and worked
um in the cycle industry
and then i decided to go into an mba i
thought i don't know anything about
business i really don't know anything
about business so i thought oh i'd like
to know about that so i'm back to
sheffield business school and did an mba
and same there i just wanted to i wanted
to learn so i think if you're motivated
to learn and want to learn it changes
something changes in your mind it's
amazing to hear that yeah like
absolutely something changed if you can
i don't know if you unlock the desire
you're not learning because it's uh
you're not learning because you have to
or you know it's not learning because
it's a must-do kind of thing but you
learn because you want to and then
it
the whole process life's learning isn't
it life's all about learning really
and um and so i think if you can unlock
that then then you're on to something
and luckily i think um i think i did and
then
eventually the first contact i had with
the british olympic program it was back
in 1997 with a guy called peter keane
and atlanta britain won one gold medal i
think in the entire olympic games which
is
ridiculously bad i mean yeah it's so bad
it's like i can't even imagine how that
happened you know but they did anyway
and at that point um john major brought
in the national lottery
with a view that half of the money half
of the property was going to go into
culture and the arts and um and the rest
was going to go into sports and the real
kind of goal of sport was to get the
country up the olympic table which was
unheard of you know it's like they were
all amateur governing bodies it was like
a dream scenario and um and cycling was
very very fortunate that they had a guy
at a time called peter king very very
bright guy visionary guy
and he wrote a beautiful plan amazing
amazing plan then i kind of met him
in in and around 1997 and i got my own
little consultancy business at the time
and we started i started to help out and
i got more engaged and i thought god
this is
this is a combination of everything i've
done sort of in my life really you know
got the the sporting side the
performance planning side you've got the
psychology of it all
it's new it's like could be a first time
ever kind of scenario the ambition is
amazing
and there's a bit of business wrapped in
there as well you know so it's i just
saw it and i thought right i'm getting
my elbows out and
i'm not missing that chance you know
it's like i thought right this is my
calling and i'm going for it i love i so
much of that i wanted to pick up on the
the point you made first about learning
it resonates so strongly with me again
um i was kicked out of school but just
exceptionally obsessed with learning as
an adult and it goes to speaks to the
fact that um
the reason my attendance was 30 in
school was i was being
pushed to walk down an alley i didn't
want to walk down yeah exactly exactly
you know what i mean yeah absolutely and
everyone's unmotivated when you try and
get them to do something that they
intrinsically don't want to do right and
this is i think a lot of the problem
with the schooling system but when i as
you were talking i was reflecting all
these messages i get from kids who like
label themselves as unmotivated
but in whose eyes right in the eyes of
their parents who want them to be a
doctor
or in the eyes of society that wants
them to do a nine-to-five but i i reject
the idea that they are unmotivated you
know a million percent i couldn't agree
more you know i've worked with a lot of
people over the years
and um i think you've got to find out
what what's there what's an individual's
intrinsic motivate what's driving
somebody inside what they really want to
do and you've got to unleash that in the
end
you know that's what life's about isn't
it really there's nobody there shouldn't
be any we shouldn't be pigeonholed and
and there shouldn't be lines and lanes
and
i'm very very very lucky that i try and
get to help other people be the best
version of themselves basically
and you think you know it
when you when you no longer compete for
yourself and you think right i'm going
to be judged
on somebody else's performance that's
what people judge me and they go like
well did somebody else win a race not me
i can't you know i'm never going to win
a race but that it's like did somebody
else win a race and then you realize
well if i'm going to be judged on on
somebody else's performance
i better get pretty good at
understanding how to optimize and help
somebody be the best they could possibly
be
and then you think well what what does
that look like how do you that what
where's this where's
why is that you know and that's where
you think well let's take the human
being as a as a as a thing
you think how do you help a human being
be the best they could possibly be are
there certain things that if you can
generally get those things right it
helps
an individual in the main
be the best version of themselves but
the first thing you got to ask is like
is that person what is that person's
internal intrinsic drive because if it's
not aligned if not really committed and
really driven and excited to what you'd
like them to be doesn't matter how much
you'd like them to be if they're not
they're not
and there's nothing you can do about
that you know but if there's a little
bit of a flicker of of of the light
burning there you can turn that up i
think you can turn it down you can very
easily turn it off by mistake or
deliberately if he isn't that way minded
but i think you do
the very essence of people achieving
things is is they've got to be driven or
they've got there's got to be a reward
i mean avoiding
you know avoidance is a very very strong
motivator as well i think and you know
maybe i had to argue that maybe in my
life i was avoiding
failure or you know that rather than
being dragged towards the positive
emotion of winning you know the positive
emotion of winning for me isn't that
great unfortunately i wish it was
but avoiding failure is massive driver
for me so um and so you know either way
you figure out what somebody's drive is
and then you help them then you think
about what you need to do to create the
environment around somebody
to optimize what they're doing and then
and then you've really got to put
yourself into somebody else's shoes
and forget yourself forget your
preconcept really genuinely say right
i'm going to stand in this person's
person's shoes
i'm going to try and see what life looks
like
for them and feel what life life looks
like for them
and really understand regardless of what
any preconceptions i might have
what what does that feel and look like
and what do they need
what would the best thing i could do
what do they need to help or support
the more you go through that
the more you kind of recognize as we're
all different but there are some common
denominators deep down inside i think
and
and if you take the time to listen to
people they might not want to tell you
first and foremost but if you dig away
at it you know eventually people will
tell you
what works for them what they like what
they don't like and if you listen
carefully you know people you get give
them a bit of ownership and they'll tell
you you know and
and and that is probably
one of the most powerful
drivers i think that that exists really
you know you can put a gun in somebody's
head ask them to jump up and down
they'll jump up and down and you [ __ ] it
and you cut the trigger and say jump
higher they'll jump higher or they'll
try to anyway and then you pull it away
and you walk away and they're not gonna
that that is not a pleasant experience
it's used a lot and it's useless in
sport actually and so less so now but
certainly has been in the past
and um but your performance is going to
be
inconsistent i think through that
and it's certainly not going to be a
very pleasurable experience and and i
think by
going down the route of trying to find
people's carrots as it were i mean
you'll have known i'm sure you've i
think you've you've interviewed steve
haven't you still yeah he's been an
amazing guy
and um
and his work i think is just phenomenal
and and something i buy into but i do
believe that it's carrot not the stick
on that point of um finding out what
their true
motivation is what they truly want and
checking that it's aligned with yours as
a coach or as a team
if you ask somebody they'll typically
give you the what they think you want to
hear answer so if i was sat in front of
you and you asked me and i was new to
your team i'd say i want to be a world
champion because i think that's what you
want to hear how do you see past that
i'm asking this because a lot of people
have people in their lives whether it's
a friend or a sibling or a son or a
daughter who they're trying to motivate
to be something and
often failing because they want it more
than that person wants it for themselves
how do you see past that um is there a
technique is it just intuitive
well i think you've got to you know as
soon as i sit down in some in front of
somebody and they think okay this guy's
got some kind of influence over what
happens to me
then it's biased immediately yeah and of
course if you don't recognize that if i
just take face value what people are
telling me now then
that's um
it's naive i think really and i think
you've got to go beyond that like you're
saying i think most people will have a
network
and you know
and and you can identify if you watch
the spheres of influence or the kind of
who's influencing who and the who who
has good relationships with who you know
if i ask you now what your drivers are
in this scenario in the scenario we're
currently in you'll kind of think about
what you're going to say really yeah
yeah whereas i think if you took if i
took give me a give me a couple of weeks
i think i could piece together slowly
but surely by chatting to you chatting
to other people asking the right
questions giving you some time
you know different different kind of
environments and some form or some
informal slowly but surely you you could
piece together a
relatively good picture of where you
think somebody's at
is it a person who's driven by you know
i like order and discipline and process
or is it somebody who wants harmony is
it somebody who wants to be life and
soul of the party and out there and
express themselves
or is it equally somebody who
you know wants to please others
and if it is pleasing others and who is
is the parents quite often i see that
really and then you know you just piece
it all together and once you have that
then you're armed with information
you're armed with something which is you
should really then respond
and and and think carefully about
you know what is this person all about
you know can you draw a map of somebody
can you really map out some of these
drivers who they are what do you think
their their influences are what do they
really want what's their you know what's
pulling them and what's pushing them
and i think when you get into that kind
of realm of high performers and
people who are really pushing themselves
to extreme levels
there's something pulling or pushing
them pretty hard normally and trying to
just understand that and dig a little
bit around that
at least like i say it gives you the
you know
i think it's an obligation for somebody
in in our kind of roles as it were to
make that effort to make sure you do
take the time to fully understand
somebody
have you encountered instances
in your career where someone's got so
much talent but they're just lacking in
drive and no matter what you've done 100
yeah and what do you do in those
situations well in our world you
wouldn't work with them you know i
wouldn't work with them i'd support them
and be very very
you know not not
unpleasant or unkind or everything else
but it's not going to work
that's the you know you have to have you
have to have that commitment
and that drive and you know that's got
to be there if that's not there then
don't go past square one really you know
and um when you're young you know you
can perform and get to a very high
standard on your talent but then when
you get to the top of the top as it were
and there's maybe five or six
people who have this a similar level of
talent and and some can get the best out
of themselves and get that little bit
you know it's like this you can get at a
normal kind of high level of performance
and then every now and again you get
this like discretionary level of
performance that little bit on top
thinking wow that was absolutely me or
you at your best and
and and we're not in the business of
that you know the high level performance
we're in the business of trying to get
that discretionary performance as as
often as possible when it really matters
and that's what you know that's what we
really got to think about and it's
unlikely that you'll get there on talent
alone
and even in the most sort of out there
sort of talents
who can be flamboyant or do the
unexpected et cetera
they've nearly all
it it's
they're all committed and very very very
bought into and driven by what they're
doing
quick one
i can't talk about huel enough in my
life especially right now going into the
end of the year i've got incredibly
exceptionally busy and it's really
interesting because what we tend to see
at this time of year
is the first thing that goes is our diet
quickly followed by our fitness and we
see that in the data across multiple
surveys however a really useful crutch
during this period where the seasons
have changed and we're starting to
behave a little bit differently is
making sure your fridge is stocked with
things that are nutritionally complete
healthy and that are going to be
convenient for you to consume without
compromising your health and that is
where ladies and gentlemen huel comes in
and they now have four brand new flavors
they have the salted caramel flavor
absolutely love they have the cinnamon
swirl flavor the number one new flavor
in my opinion which is really surprising
iced coffee caramel and they have the
strawberries and cream flavor if you're
going to try any of the new flavors
please do try the cinnamon swirl and let
me know what you think it's an
absolutely unexpected champion of the
new flavors
that word commitment is um the first
letter in your acronym
core
which is part it's a philosophy you're
known for what is this core philosophy
what is the acronym acronym and uh what
does it stand for to be fair to you know
i just mentioned steve peters i think um
you know one of the great things i think
that i've been very very fortunate to to
have happened in my life was that we i
met steve back in i think it was 2002
something like you know around that i
was always into you know i liked
psychology obviously i studied
psychology but
i couldn't quite it wasn't quite input
output enough it wasn't i don't know it
didn't feel quite solid enough at times
and then we had an athlete who had
you know had a bit of an issue and
somebody within our medical team had
been a student
of steve's at the uh school of medicine
in uh in sheffield
and they said well we could ask this guy
to come across and he did and and he did
this amazing piece of work with with his
athletes i thought wow i really got to
meet this guy and so i sat down
uh with steve and his um psychiatrist
not a psychologist obviously a forensic
psychiatrist and he sat down and he said
right well here's my mental kind of map
as it were and this is how your brain
works and this is the different parts of
your brain think differently and you
know you you know you do realize that
this different um your blood goes to
different areas and and then so you'll
be driven by emotion or logic or by past
experiences etc
and i was like okay this is really
interesting and that what i liked about
tim he was like if you do this then
that's and you should do this not that
and he's quite prescriptive
um in a very neutral way but quite
strong and i really like that really
really like that so i thought wow this
guy would be absolutely
dynamite in sport and so steve was still
working in um in the uh nhs and he was
actually working at rampton
at the time as well with you know the
mass murders and the psychopaths and all
that and so i tried to persuade and says
come on you've got to come and work in
sports
and and eventually
you know he did to be fair he came and
worked full-time and it was just an
amazing period really because we sat
down and said right forget cycling for a
minute let's think about the human brain
the human being
and how do we create the best possible
environment for people to perform
and um and that's where the core
principle came from with steve in the
first instance so he was like you know
they see his commitment so let's let's
screen these people for commitment and
he'd do a commitment screen and then
he'd ask people about their homework how
they did their homework and what that
what you know when people had to do
something deliver on something he'd ask
he'd interrogate them a little bit about
that
and then the o of the call was for
ownership
and uh the idea that we we were human
will
perform better and respond better with a
little bit of ownership over what
they're doing so you know sport was very
much a dictate and control kind of
coaching model really and management
model
and
he was very much of the
you know
very very strong that
as a human we like to have a little bit
of control of what's happening to us we
like to negotiate or have a little say
this works that works and
and that's a very powerful kind of
construct to work with
um the r was for responsibility
and accountability and of course we've
all
work in professional jobs in the end and
we've all got accountability and
responsibility in life
and um and so people need to be held
accountable and responsible and then the
eu is for excellence but it's personal
excellence
and as he used to joke about he should
have been personal excellence but it
sounded a bit like corpse
so we stuck with core and um and so we
got all the coaches in and said i i i
bought this 100
really really thought right we're going
to do this and then we'll sort of use
cycling as the kind of
you know not
well it was it was the opportunity to to
do something different you know and i
was absolutely sure
really really sure it was the right
thing to be doing of course he was there
to sort of coach and help and support
and um so we've got the coaches in he
said right guys we're going to change
the way we're we're working here um
we're going to put the the time actually
we termed it going to take the crown
um
off the heads of the coaches and put
them onto the heads of the riders
and they're going to be the come the
kings and queens of their own world
their own destiny and we're going to
support them in that and it was just a
slight change of emphasis
which you know a lot of the coaches
threw their hands in the air well you
would that would be out of control they
weren't training and
you know it was kind of an emotional
response really and of course
you know chris hoy and vicki pendleton
and all these other you know all of the
athletes who were with us at the time
they wanted to perform for themselves
yeah they weren't performing for a coach
they weren't you know
they might have a brilliant relationship
with a coach
because they they were they were after
their own performance or a team
performance it wasn't it wasn't done for
the coach and it was a it was a real
i mean it sounds a bit
obvious now i guess but at the time it
felt like a quite a big deal to be to be
really empowering
a group of athletes and um
yeah enough we went with that really and
um it was an exciting time
one of the things that i've taken from
that many things but one of the things
that i've taken from that which is again
feels really consistent throughout lots
of things i've read about you is this
idea of going back to first principles
to make to create better solutions
and i'll tell you the three touch points
where i've kind of
i've i've seen that in your philosophy
the first is you basically went down to
the first principles of the human brain
there and said how does the human brain
work and let's treat the human brain in
a better way
outside of the conventional way of
treating the human brain to get a better
outcome that's like again with first
principles it's a lot of work no one
wants to do it conventions but much
easier the second thing is just
generally your attitude to breaking down
what you were trying to achieve as a
team into small sections that's where i
see the first principles thing and the
third thing was i read that you hired
younger coaches into your team that
weren't tainted with convention and
again they're much easier to train in in
new ways is that
yes i think in the making that's i think
i do like to break things down into
you know as small as component bars or
first principles anyway it's not copy
and paste yeah you know i read a lot and
and i'm constantly kind of reading and
listening to podcasts and i'm constantly
taking information in
but and i'll use some of the information
but i won't just copy and paste it i
won't just apply it it's contextual i'd
like to understand what's going on
behind it like to understand the theory
and the thinking it drives people mad
actually because
i can talk about
methods and whatnot and models all day
long you know
but
fundamentally it's how it's how i like
to work and um
i think it's like the the true tickets
down to its kind of deepest sort of
simplest level of understanding and then
construct it relative to the context or
the situation how it could best apply to
what you're doing and take the time you
know take the time and effort and the
energy and the
you know i'd like to think about it and
i'll draw it i'll draw
non-stop so i don't write so much i draw
and then i cover my office wall in like
sticky
plastic stuff on the wall and draw over
the walls looks like a mud man's in
there i must admit but it's how it's
what i like to do and it's how i work so
it drives a couple of people a little
bit crazy but um
i think they used to buy now but but i
do like to do that and then and then if
you get a real understanding for
something then you can you can see
whether you really agree with the with
the fundamental principles and either go
with what go with that or question it
and develop your own ideas
and like development if you're going to
develop your own ideas do it
sort of um with originally as it were
rather than necessarily just kind of um
taking something as well and just
applying it you know i'm not don't be a
bit uncomfortable with i think one of
the things that
definitely felt very original when i was
reading about um your philosophy is this
idea of forgetting about the results
because thinking about the results or
the outcome of your performance can
reduce the chances of success in that
performance that's very unusual because
in in teams in
competition in business we think about
the result we think about closing the
deal or you know what and what that will
mean and we kind of imagine ourselves in
that moment of getting the medal around
our neck or that business deal one why
is that not a good idea well if if an
event happens or something happens the
first thing that's going to happen to
you without you even knowing is you're
going to have an unconscious emotional
reaction to it and it's emotion
it's not you're not thinking it through
it's just purely emotion
and that that that's going to be you
know either it's sort of a fight flight
freeze response really and um but that
that emotional
response will happen quicker than you
know it before you can go in and get any
logic or get any rationale enter into it
and of course in um in any kind of
situation like uh
you know what could be perceived as a
threat state where you're putting
yourself in in some kind of threatening
scenario a bit of damage my pride or you
know what people what happens to people
they start thinking well what happens if
i win ones have to lose ones i've looked
ridiculous i don't look ridiculous
i'm under threats and that then becomes
you know very easy to get emotionally
hijacked by that so then you're purely
ringing on an emotion which is
inconsistent it's illogical you know
it's not a it's not a good way for you
to be basing it's not a good place for
you to be basing your behavior
but if you understand that and you think
okay well look i understand that it's
normal that i'm going to put myself in a
threatening scenario so if i worry about
let my emotion take over and i worry
about what happens if i succeed what
happens if i fail what happens if this
what happens if that's
then it's actually a pointless exercise
and if you can train slowly recognize
and train your mind to go okay i know
what's happening here this is just
emotion i'm going to put it to one side
now then
let me separate this whatever i'm doing
out into two things we can have a a
dream i want to win the tour de france
it's a dream
my ability to win it or our ability or
anybody else is to win it is i'm going
to do my absolute best to try and win it
but other people are going to try and
stop me and other people are going to
try to do something it's stuff beyond
our control that could impact on that so
if you set your goal
as i'm going to win
you're going to agitate non-stop because
it actually is out of your control
whereas if you set your dream and saying
this is what i'd really really like to
happen i'll go all in i'll do everything
i can i'm fully committed to that but
let me break it down into
targets which is well it'd be i i could
get to the ideal weight i could do the
proper training i could do the you know
follow a nutritional plan that's going
to give me the optimal energy and
you know i can train my tactics i can be
really work hard to get a fantastic team
around me build good rapport build
confidence in my teammates these are all
things that you can do
and so if you say okay let's leave the
dream over there for a while but i'm
going to go after the things i can do
and you base your plan
around the things that you can actually
control and do you'll be on fire you'll
be on fire you'll be absolutely on fire
and the dream might happen and it might
not then you'll be absolutely oh you
know delighted and
the best thing ever if it happens and if
it doesn't then you might be absolutely
devastated but you've got to leave as a
dream then you've got to understand that
actually worrying about the consequence
of an event
it's detrimental to the process and the
performance and the the chances of you
achieving that event so you park that
go after your targets and go right i'm
going process my outcome and we talked a
lot about process and outcome and when
you catch yourselves you know it's
emotion in the end so of course we do
get hijacked and of course we do get
fearful or you know a bit panicked and
you gotta you gotta have a system
whereby you can talk with yourself a
little bit you can bring yourself back
around and focus on the now and the
process of now
rather than worrying about the future
and then you can come back and
concentrate on the process get back into
the now and you know some of the
athletes would would have a routine
where they'd tie the undo and tie the
shoelaces again or they do they'd have a
little
you know a little process that they'd
tap into and they'd go into that in
internet and bring their mind back into
the present
and stop worrying about the future and
of course the penalty kick's the best
example yeah that's what i was thinking
about now this did their yeah i'm sure
they they bag 100 in training yeah
exactly in the euros final exactly you
know and if you take the crowd out and
take a penalty those guys are so
accurate and the you know signal from
the brain down into the muscle to
contract in a certain way
that happens and the accuracy and the
repeatability of that is is absolutely
massive put a crowd in there and what
changes nothing changes physically it's
all between your ears
and so how can you train that you know
and mental skills can be trained just as
much as you you know we all know that
but we want to get fit and strong and
you go to the gym and you know that
you're going to overload your body
you're going to give it time to adapt
and it's adaptation it's going to make a
little bit stronger and it's the same
with a mind you know you can train your
mind and and i think that's what
certainly working with steve was
was an eye opener
as well as i think probably the biggest
item for most people is it gives you a
once you realize you've got like an
emotional
brain and a logical brain and you know a
bit of a memory
computer side going on then then it
gives you insight into yourself and why
you are behaving and feeling like you
are
and some of the assumptions you're
making about other people then you got
to start with yourself first
if you can get a little bit of insight
why do i feel how i'm feeling why do i
respond like i do what triggers me
what's my best self look like and what's
my sort of you know not the best self
i've got why why am i different
why sometimes am i behaving in this kind
of you know the second or the shadow
version of myself and what are some of
someone's in my best self what's
happening there why can't it just be my
best self all the time surely that must
be doable so take a bit of time to
understand it and pick it and some
people just maybe haven't been educated
i certainly wasn't until really i still
sort of stopped and started to look at
this stuff and then you realize think
wow
a lot of my behavior a lot of my life
was driven by emotion it wasn't driven
by the real me who could be calm and
logical and think things through and
quite you know a lot of passion and
feelings and caring and and yet at times
i could be something else you know
and i think understanding that's
fundamental i think i don't think
there's any excuse for that no okay um
both points sounded very similar in fact
because on one hand you're saying with
your goals only go after things you can
control like really focus on those
things and in the same way when we're
talking about personal responsibility of
self you're saying
you can't control other people
so yeah but the thing that you know
maybe you do have control over in your
life is your behavior how you act how
you conduct yourself and then kind of
leave
the rest uh well i think you understand
how the people are responding and how
they're feeling so you can accept that
if somebody's um you know somebody's in
a very
there's two things really i think first
and foremost ambition is a big thing not
to forget you know what's your level um
you can be incredibly ambitious why
can't we be the best in the world or
something why can't be the first to do
something what's stopping us doing
something that nobody ever in the human
race has ever done before nothing as far
as i can see you know so i think there's
a
it's
um you know you've got to have that
ambition enthusiasm the belief we can do
whatever we want to do you know and
really stretch that and then i think the
next bit really the targets it's more
like the the how to get there yeah it's
more like the boring stuff to get there
you know so it's like head and heart
really
um and i think that
if you understand yourself then you
should be able to put yourself in
somebody else's shoes and if they're
having a tough time or
if somebody else is angry or there's
something else going on with them you
know rather than just dive in
and and respond to the behavior you see
in a face value why not stop and think
about a little bit and is this person in
trouble what's causing this where are
they coming from what's going on you
know trying to understand it and if
they're just responding emotionally to
something and you allow yourself to
immediately respond emotionally back it
doesn't really get anywhere you know so
so you better hold back and wait and
find out and
and try anyway not always easy but not
always easy no no i struggle with that
yeah i struggle with that especially
being in a environment where my my time
is so feels so precious right it's
always there's so many things i could be
doing and i'm you're exactly you're
exactly the same i know i've you know i
know people that work with you i know
you're a very very busy person
so it's it's tough in the moment to stop
and pause and to have patience when the
rest of my life is run on like
efficiency yeah yeah you know what i
mean
it's difficult
yeah i guess in in my world you know i'm
out to try and help people and i do push
people and we've got high standards and
you know you do want a level i don't
like laziness for example i just can't
that that that would really work that
gets me you know but then i have to
manage it and think okay well if they
that's what they want and there's no
problem this just this isn't the
environment for them you know
but
in the main i think understanding
challenges and and
setting standards and
boundaries and working to all of that is
important um you built teams and
developed teams that won over and over
and over again in the same way that sir
alex ferguson did our manchester united
fan so i was lucky enough to be you know
not going so well lately but in that era
to watch our team win over and over
again yeah yeah yeah and the thing that
really um
i find because i just thought that was
normal growing up that my team wins all
the time yeah the thing i find amazing
now when i look back on it is how he
managed to reinvent those teams but also
to get the same team to win again and i
this this idea of like where is your
motivation after victory and how do you
get a team that's just one and then they
win again and i went again to win again
yeah where do they find the motivation
they've stolen the podium they've had
the moment where does that come from
yeah it's a great question that one and
i think um and i think credit to sir
alex and the work that he did i mean um
you know i think now when looking back
there there are those long-serving
successful managers who like you say
whilst it's happening it's an error or
nobody really kind of thinks too much
it's just the norm but then when you
realize it's not actually the norm at
all you know it's it's something very
very special going on and i think the i
think success is interesting in in terms
of what it does to people and you know i
think in sport we're kind of more geared
to failure really you lose more than you
win normally
and
you know we kind of recalibrate the
goals dust yourself down and
redo your plan and off you go again
but when you succeed all of a sudden not
many people have a plan for success you
know what i mean so you succeed nobody's
gotta
nobody wants to tempt i guess but not
many people have a plan for success and
it does it does impact on people
massively in terms of the expectation of
themselves on their in terms of their
hunger going forward you know it does it
does impact people in different ways and
of course you get more
you probably get financially better off
you you
your position society changes you know
who you are legacy whatever whatever
whatever and of course all that all that
can change and impact on your drive and
your hunger and i think fundamentally
that's the bit that's incredible about
the people who stay at the top for a
long time it's not really the reward and
you know what they what they're getting
sort of
financially you know you those are the
kind of sort of
trappings of success i don't think
that's what driving them you know
there's something else deeper down
driving those people forward and they'll
just keep going and going and going and
i thought what um
alex ferguson did ever so well
was he
there's always a challenge with teams
when you've got a generation who grow
together and they come together and
you'll have a two three four years of
amazing success with a group who've
bonded and they're on a journey together
and of course then you start to get
towards the end of that and at what
point you bring
young talent in
and let some of the more established
talent go you know and there's a
transition
and he did that ever so well he really
did that ever so well
and we met and chatted a couple of times
about that just when when i was younger
up in the velodrome in manchester he'd
pop over to the velodrome
and we'd sit there and chat and that was
always one of the big things i wanted to
ask him you know i was like okay what
what are you watching what are you
seeing uh
why are you doing this what you know
what have you seen there that makes you
think that's the right time to change
and you're bringing this youngster in
here you know and he'd say you know he
he quite often say that
um you know people get a bigger voice
they get a bigger standing in the
dressing room they might start to second
you know i'm not so sure about that cafe
you know
and they'd have an influence and
you know there'd be
the celebrity the media and other things
going on et cetera et cetera and
definitely sooner rather than later that
would be right okay
off we go we'd and he changed it
listening to him talk about it he knew
exactly what he's doing to be fair to
him and he was a master at it
you've got to have had moments like that
in your career where you see that
culture
at threat or at risk because of an
individual i've had them in my business
too
and in those moments
very early in my career i would try and
i guess look past when i was a bit more
naive in business look past it or put
things in place to try and mitigate the
impact that one individual the negative
impact that one individual was having on
the overall culture
and as i got older i realized that i
just needed to address the situation
asap before it becomes like a virus and
spreads right yeah yeah what do you do
in that situation where you see an
individual in your company it's a tough
one
it really is i mean it's an easy one to
talk about it's a very difficult one to
do
um particularly when you know that might
be your best
player your best rider your best
performer
and all of a sudden you've got the
hitting the numbers and and the behavior
is not great
and then you've got to ask yourself well
we have to just win in and it doesn't
really matter just win um
and you kind of manage the impact of
that across everybody
or does behavior and conduct and culture
matter and you want to make sure that
you actually got some cultural values
that you're going to stand by
come come what may you know and of
course
those real moments
when they do arrive and you've got to
address it they're very very
stressful
i i kind of get very
introspective and look myself in the
mirror and think it through and think it
through
and everybody works for me and say it
takes me time to make a decision and i
think because i think of every
permutation and i think it through so
much
emotionally i fully i don't think i
can't actually i'm just so engaged with
those things
that i've really really got to think
carefully about them and about to make a
couple of
pretty big decisions along along those
lines and in the end i thought what do i
believe in
is a popular decision
is it a performance decision
in my world you know there's like we
we're trying to win here or
do we want to keep people happy or where
where do we go and you need some kind of
you need to establish your own right
what do i believe in
and without really figuring out what you
believe in you're always going to be
caught in a storm otherwise and it's
always going to be mentally excruciating
i think because you're never quite sure
so i i like like to anchor myself and
write what are my values what i believe
in and how does that apply to this
situation and then okay well that's it
and if it goes wrong i always want to be
able to look back and say okay well i
made decisions based on my principles i
didn't make decisions based on that
particular moment doesn't matter how
difficult it was and i'll stick to that
now but i've had one quite recently
actually or two actually in the last
two to three months which would pretty
challenging
decisions like that and on both
occasions i've gone right back and i
tend to
i thought it was a good thing probably
not a good thing for the people around
me but i got a few you know people i
really value their opinion you know and
they're sort of like you know i'll chat
away to them and i'll ask them questions
and
and i think sometimes i think okay you
know i'm going to make that decision or
he's asking me to make this decision
what i'm trying to do is just kind of
run through my thought processes and
sound it out sounded out and sounded
outstanding
until i get really pretty anchored onto
no i know what i really feel now and
then i'll make the decision immediately
i won't hesitate then but to get to that
point takes me a bit of time i need to
talk about it to somebody i need to i
need to express it vocally i think to
really make sure i understand what i'm
thinking because if i can't explain it
to somebody i'm maybe not quite there so
just thinking about in my own head or
even writing it down for myself
on big stuff i like to try and be able
to explain it to somebody
to then understand fully that i really
if i can explain it to somebody i think
i pretty much got it
whereas if i just in my head explain it
to myself
what the hell i'm talking about you know
so yeah it's quite um it's a quite an
agonizing process but you just need
principles in the end you need the
decision making
framework framework yeah basically you
do yeah so because everyone can relate
to that even if they've not been in your
position i mean we all have we'll face
really tough moments but we kind of
arrive at that that pass and we have to
decide if we're going left or right and
the worst possible thing is making often
making no decision right
making no decision or or making a
decision that you thought was the right
decision because you thought it was the
right thing to do but it wasn't actually
what you thought
and i think we're always fearful of the
consequences of our decision so i think
quite often and i say to our guys
sometimes okay imagine
let's let's imagine we've got a problem
and take away you know we're going to
have a group discussion about something
and imagine that all of our riders
didn't have emotions they were just
robots
and what would you do and they got
simple well you just do this this and
this
okay so now put the emotions back in
then that's that's what's that doing to
you why is that changing your thinking
and then of course you don't you know
got people's feelings and you might have
conflict you might somebody might not be
happy and you know that that then
impacts because we're trying to
second-guess
the emotional response of a group or
he's trying to second-guess how somebody
might feel or whether they're gonna come
at you or it creates conflict or
you know and and so i think it's every
now and again i go right okay let's just
up the robots like what would we do what
was the best thing to do and they go
simple we'll just do this and so that's
that's one thing
i think if you think that right
the consequence of whatever decided
about
nothing bad happens
nothing bad happens
absolutely there is so you can make any
decision you want and nothing happens
nothing bad happens what would you do
and people's mind freed up immediately
they'll make a good decision probably
but it's fear or is there it's the
it's the consequence of this might
happen or that might happen or it might
go wrong or this or that or the other
they might not be happy or they might
not be you know and it impacts your
decision-making really so you get all
these biases these emotional biases all
the time and don't get me wrong
sometimes a gut gut feel is a good thing
you know so but on the other hand i
think if you strip out the consequence
of like nothing bad would happen
and also people's other people's
emotions what would you do
most people get pretty quickly to yeah
where they'd want to be you know i just
bit then in my head about some of the
big decisions i have in my life i
thought there was no if i was dealing
with robots and i could just shuffle
things without consequence yeah what
would i do exactly and that the answer
you're seeing there is probably
the right thing for the objective
exactly but maybe well you could also
say well there are emotion um there's
emotional consequences which might
hinder the objective
so if i really annoy this person or if i
upset the balance here then the
objectives compromise so yeah exactly
and yeah it just helps a little bit
in the end you know it's like it's like
taking out if you've got bad tooth
you've got to take it out i might as
well take it out quick
exactly it's going to hurt just as much
in a couple of months time you know so
might as well take it out now yeah
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy
ever since i sold my range over sport
and bought an electric bicycle and my
energy as a sponsor of this podcast one
of the brands that make that transition
much much easier they are at the
forefront of british renewable ecosmart
technology and their products are really
really changing the game if you're on
youtube you can see what i'm holding in
my hand this is called the eddie right
it's the uk's number one solar powered
diverter so what is a solar diverter
it's a device for people like you and me
that means you can divert your excess
energy back into your home rather than
back into the grid which will save you
power and money it's super user friendly
and easy to install and you can control
it using the my energy app on your phone
to find out more about this product and
more products like here that will help
you make that sustainable transition
head over to myenergy.com and um i
highly recommend you check out the eddie
it's um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
marginal gains i do you know what i have
to say
this podcast is doing very well
uh i think it's maybe number one in
europe now but i have to give you a lot
of credit for that
because i think my team are sick and
tired i can see them laughing over there
they're sick and tired of me saying this
phrase we've got to find the one percent
and for us in what we do with this
podcast i mean it's it's in my
businesses as well but in this podcast
it means like really giving a
f about everything from the audio to
these eight cameras that are on us
nobody else does it like we do it with
eight cameras and the robots and this
and the thumbnail the title the way you
were picked up today yeah how you leave
to really make even when you walk in
there we were a little bit slow on it
today but the music to create the right
atmosphere yeah the lighting we've
installed these blinds here because
we're trying to we want you looking at
me because it's about all of these small
things and
i never
heard that directly from you but i heard
it indirectly by you as in my friends
would tell me about this thing called
marginal gains from this guy called
david brailsford and i like adopted it
as a personal philosophy maybe i adopted
it as a personal philosophy or it made
my existing philosophy make sense
yeah okay yeah yeah probably either one
you know sometimes
so thank you for that but i guess my
question because that has genuinely
really helped me communicate
um why small
things are so important but
as it relates to marginal gains how
marginal
huh good question and how marginal was
smiles marginal three the smiles
marginal yeah okay oh they're good i
like people your best marginal gain ever
smile at people more often cheapest and
easier exactly and people like it people
smile back
i wonder what the trajectory
how that impacts your trajectory through
life if you just smiled more a lot yeah
other thoughts so you know you'd be more
approachable people think he's a
friendly person you know just in the
main you know smile at people smile each
other say hello
and walk past you know don't you're not
so that you can't be all so consumed in
your head that you're walking around
with your head down and
ignoring people you know which which was
very easy to do you know somebody says
hello
that's a marginal gain right there
people don't value the small stuff they
focus too much on the big stuff right
well i think you've got to get the
basics right you know i think i think
the marginal gains concept came about
originally
is when we started out with the olympic
program and the olympic kind of medals
were so far away you know it seemed like
such a mountain and they were so so
in the distance and untouchable they
think like wow
how on earth what are we going to do to
get from where we are now to get up
there
and as we kind of as we started working
through
you know what what are we how we're
going to approach this
it occurred to me that there was a
couple of things really one was
there's obviously the
the fundamentals the basics of any kind
of performance really when if you get
the fundamentals right for a consistent
period of time it's going to get you a
long way there it really is so that
that's there's no you know that that's
important
but the um
the whole idea of marginal gains really
starts to start to think right okay so
we're we're pretty long way off up there
but so what can we do what can we
believe in how do we get some momentum
how do we get some contagious enthusiasm
of course people like a little bit of
progression you know
and if we just aim for perfection
perfection is so far away that there's
no point because we're gonna fail every
day so i thought well let's have a
little progression
just a little little bit of progression
and i made you feel good you know so
it's like let's identify where we go and
we're doing the basics right then what
could we do by next week that we're not
doing this week what little things could
we do there's a million things that
could impact
a cycling performance could we could we
i don't know change our diet
to be slightly more optimal than it is
this week and do that by next week and
everybody goes yep we could do that
okay what else could we do could we do
more in the in the gym could we do could
you change your attitude slightly could
be really kind of think about just even
engage with thinking about your attitude
once a day could you do that yeah we
could do that
okay so off we go and then you get to
next week and did we do all that stuff
yeah we did actually and we haven't
moved a long way but i'll tell you what
i felt pretty good what are you doing i
did this what are you doing i did this
and all of a sudden you kind of started
getting this idea of you you make you
you're on the move
and the one of the things about marginal
gains is you're on the move
and we like progression we like to feel
well quite good about myself today i did
x probably means nothing to anybody else
and probably probably you know very you
know unique to me but it meant something
to me you know and i feel quite good
about that and so i can i can do that
again tomorrow and small
small steps stick well if you're trying
to do something big you can go with
something big for a little while we'll
all go to the gym in january now in a
couple of months a couple of weeks time
we'll go full gas in the gym and then
course by february or mid february we've
all stopped again not you know
generalization but you know what i mean
and um and why is that you know whereas
we're trying to make too big a change
that's not sustainable
and and it's it's it's quite rare that
you can make major change and make it
sustainable but it's quite easy to make
small incremental change and make them
stick and it's the stickability over
time
i think which makes the the big
difference and it's as much
psychological as is anything else and if
there's a group who buy into right let's
look at the little things you know let's
look at the difference let's look at the
you know your setup in here like the
music and everything once you start
doing that everybody's on the you know
getting quite excited yeah that's what
makes us different and then somebody's
going to go well we could have that
picture instead of that picture we could
do this instead of that
and it feels good and by virtue of the
fact that you're all going you're on in
you're enjoying it and there's a bit of
energy about it then other ideas will
come to the surface you'd be more open
to to adopting them and people talk
about it you know we're on the move
we're changing we're doing all these
little things because we can be asked to
do the little things that other people
can't be asked to do
and that makes a difference that makes
you a winner in my opinion i might say
that quite often in our team you know
we'll be working late and i said all
right guys let's just all get together
for a minute the reason we've been good
the reason we're good is we can be asked
to do all these little things all these
other teams are now locked up they've
gone to bed they're in the hotel they
can't be bothered to do this we can
and it matters to us that's what we're
all about now let's keep going
and it and it works you know it works
100 percent it works been at 20 years
and it's as much about that kind of
enthusiasm and a positivity about
embracing
that change isn't a chore improving
isn't a chore if it's a chore it's a bit
like saying about education you know if
if what you're trying to achieve is a
chore
then that's a that's a challenge how do
you how do you make something how do you
change somebody or reframe something
into a little bit that's not a chore or
something that actually has been over
there anything i'm gonna reframe that
into a positive
and then you'll stick with it you know
feel good about yourself in the end if
we feel good about ourselves
we're gonna be happier we're gonna be
more engaged and be more willing to make
more change if we feel good about
ourselves and and that was where sort of
marginal gains come from and i was lying
on the floor i said when i really have
to think i did this crazy thing where i
used to do my homework lying on the
floor as a kid and now when i really
really want to think you sort of really
think about something get big sheets of
paper
tend to lie on the floor and and write
on that
and um
marginal gains came from um
economics really with michael costling
that's what sort of i was reading all
about that
and about little kind of inc you know
incremental gains and i thought actually
hmm if you aggregate all of these
marginal gains maybe get a big gain yeah
but conceptually it sounded like yeah
this is worth a go and off we went
i always reference a compounding
interest as well it's like exactly the
same thing right exactly exactly you can
get one percent yeah a year look what i
say for example
i often like whip out the compounding
interest calculator on google and i'm
like just change it by one percent and
see what it looks like 20 years yeah and
the graph is just in a completely
different place yeah and that's another
really good way to get people to believe
in this invisible force that
you know is compounding for or against
you yeah these one percent yeah because
you know getting 10 interest on a
million for 30 years versus getting 11
exactly ridiculously different um at the
end of that compounding cycle
you sound like i mean you've described
yourself as being obsessed you sound
like you're pretty obsessed with what
you do
yeah i suppose i am
yeah what's the cost of that obsession
well i think you know i've pretty much
kind of put everything i've got into
what i do really and that means
currently i'll spend
220 days a year
you know at races and you know a long
time on the road and um and that does
come at a cost i guess you know and uh
um
it's hard to get out of it i think
i don't know if it's obsessive or not i
suppose
you know i've obviously got uh
millie my daughter
who
um
i love absolutely adorable love to bits
and um
you know we we've spent i guess since
she was born i've always been
you know
in involved in in sport
and um
at some point soon i'd like to think
right i'm going to stop and really spend
time more time together that would be
nice
and that and and yet
i think if i was thinking why am i doing
all of this i think a lot would be you
know i'd like her to be happy i'd like
her to have
whatever whatever she can have really
and uh
yeah it's a tough battle that's
balancing out that one that doesn't come
easy to me i can i can tell i was just
trying to visualize you sat on a beach
with your
cigar with no work no sports
yeah i think i would i think i'd
i i would like to just i think have a
period where i just maybe just switch
off you know i've had a holiday for a
long time and
i've had a few health issues obviously
at a you know
issue with my heart this year and i have
a cancer
and that kind of forced me to stop a
little bit but then i got back to his
accord
and and carried on so
i think i'd like yeah i would like to
just
at some point learn to maybe take time
out
[Music]
and enjoy the
color of life a little bit more and the
various things in life but um yeah
you mentioned that um getting getting
news that i mean we all hope to never
get up about ourselves or our loved ones
which is that you had cancer now that's
something you can't control
no that was a shock i must say that was
a that was a
real shock i wasn't expecting at all you
know
i ride my bike you know i train hard
and um
i ride my bike a lot look after myself
and i was very fit
um
and um
and then i started to get these bouts of
fatigue more than anything and it was a
really weird kind of you know we you
race every day you're moving every day
and i think people see the sport on
telly they don't see the rigor of all
the travel and all the movement and the
early mornings of late nights and you
know you're on race for a month a three
week race you go there a week early and
you're nailed you know halfway through
and of course then you've got to really
dig into your tired a lot of time but
then start getting these bouts of
fatigue which just like somebody pulled
literally taking my battery out
and i'd well i could feel it coming on
and then that's
i just couldn't function and then i went
for a check and
[Music]
i did a blood test and then you know my
psa had gone up and
and so i said i better go for another
check and said god you know i'll be all
right and then didn't bother and then
eventually i did
and then they said yeah it's around and
said right better come and see me
straight away and and that was it
i thought it was quite a big deal at a
time but then
i moved on
i don't dwell on it i don't think about
it much i i like the sort of tough times
don't last last tough people do you know
and i just thought right that's it done
i'm not going to dwell on this i'm going
to move on
and that's what i did really as quick as
i could but those moments
give you a different type of perspective
on what matters right
well you have like kind of an
existential moment of yeah you think
about oh my god my
the tectonic plate of my health is
something that can yeah very much so
yeah i don't you wouldn't even consider
the thought of it no
no 100 percent and absolutely you're
spot on with that you know it
you realize right okay we're not here
forever
a hundred percent you know which is true
for everybody isn't it you know and they
kind of when you're younger it's one of
those things you hear older people say
and whatever but but then you have the
dawning of the realization right i'm not
here forever
so then you think okay what's important
what what you know
is it like to come back you know what
time i've got left and all that kind of
stuff
and then he starts to think about that
and
so then you start to think even more you
know a lot of people talk to you about
you know living in the moment of course
you've got a plan for the future you
can't just ignore the future because
we're all
we're all preparing the future you know
it's trying to get fitter or whatever
whatever and that's of course today
thinking about
doing something today
for your current self
but for your future self you're thinking
of your future self when we diet or
train or you know it's not going to
happen now so you your mind is on your
future self
and to what extent you're worried about
your future self and the consequences of
things happening rather than enjoying
the here and now
and i think that really does bring it
home in terms of to what extent am i
enjoying the present and living in the
present and what then i'm just going to
keep on going
and and sort of sacrificing for my
future self when my future is never
going to arrive
you know and that's a bit of an odd
question to say competent play for a
while
it's a reality check to spend any time
in hospital isn't it you know but
equally there's some amazing people
working in there and it's just yeah i
was blown away by that actually did
steve peters speak to you through this
period at all oh yeah i speak to you
i think i mean i love steve i must say
he's um
i think he had fran miller on on as well
and she'll say the same i'm sure and and
a lot of people who we worked with with
steve would say you know he's been he's
a game changer for us
and uh whenever i'm worried i'm not sure
about something
i'm kind of know what he's going to sell
me but i still like to hear anyway you
know so um so i chatted to him then and
um
about how to you know what what to deal
with i was
it upset um i didn't like it that it was
set it's upset millie i think
and i didn't like that you know i didn't
like the idea that
she was worried and and and
so that was quite um
i want i wanted to make sure that i
dealt with that properly but but then
equally
lies for a living
you know and you think okay well here i
am i'm still here and i'm going to make
the most of this you know and i'm going
to enjoy a little bit more and stop
you know worrying and and thinking and
you know constantly this this idea of
chasing and doing something for the next
events and
and it's like boys chill out a little
bit and and enjoy the things that you
like doing and in the end like most
people the things i like the most simple
things i like around my bike
i like like being out and beautiful
roads
on my bike i like i like socializing
with people i'm not a big kind of big
gathering person i'm a
you know smaller group of people and
i've got some amazing you know people
and friends and
i don't know i just like the simple
things in life really but really really
taken them in
acceptance i i was when reading and
hearing how you dealt with that
situation i think
the um
the really powerful thing that i kind of
got from that was getting to that point
of accepting the situation as fast as
you can
yeah good point yeah and i know it's a
bit cheesy as well but we talk about
yeah it's a bit of a
phrase but the whole idea of you know
when you're under pressure and you're
really in a moment of real you know okay
that the heat's on here um you know the
idea of instead of sort of trying to
resist them being like a stick and and
kind of bending bending and snapping
just think yourself as bamboo and just
bend
and you know for well that once that
once this moment's passed you're going
to snap back up you're going to be okay
and so we talk a lot about bending like
bamboo
not bending like a stick you know not
snapping and just just bend like bamboo
and we're in a bit when we're in
difficult moments we go it's just bent
we're just bending like a bamboo a pass
he'll pass
and and sure enough most times it does
we worry about stuff that never happens
don't we
always we worry about massively about
stuff that never actually happens and
and there all sorts of it brings all of
that kind of stuff home you know it
resonates after
and it's still so much joy from our
present right when we're thinking about
all that all that could go wrong and
then as you've highlighted with your
theory of focusing on the controllables
it hinders performance which is um
which is incredibly detrimental too one
of the things when i when i started
reading about your future now looking
forward you then also got the news a
couple years later this year i believe
yeah that you had but you had to have
heart surgery
that's a bit of a shock as well
yeah so so i was um
so
after the pandemic i i was riding my
bike a lot
and my uh
my dad actually was was was very ill so
i went down to as soon as we could
travel after the pandemic i went down to
to france to the alps and i was there
visiting the hospital
rode my bike and as i was riding up hill
i was getting this kind of i thought it
was a pain in the throat or something to
do with my breathing or the dry air
maybe the altitude
and as it was when i was trying pretty
hard push myself pretty out it really
started to hurt quite a lot and then
if i slowed down it subsided off it went
so i thought okay it was just going to
pass as you do
i went out for a ride with a
friend of mine the guy called nikki
craig and we were out riding and he um
and i really were right i said bra blind
i think i'm gonna have to stop here
because he's you know his pain
was getting really bad
so i thought in the end i thought well
i'm gonna have it i'll go to it i'm
gonna check it out you know just in case
i went for a ct scan of my heart and the
guy came out and he was a german guy i
said david
you have a big problem and and my uh my
left descending archery was totally
blocked
and i was literally kind of
you know they wouldn't let me that was
it they kept me there put me on the
medication straight away
and i pretty much operated on
him you know
to avoid a heart attack basically
and that was a shock that was um
that was pretty full-on really
yeah
that was more of a shock than a cancer
was i don't know why your heart feels
worse than
i don't know but it was a different it
was a different sensation that one i
must admit that i'd be worried
and that's another set of uncomfortable
conversations with millie and
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then now to go
in and um so the doctor again doctors
brilliant went in and then i thought god
i've done a typical bloke thing here
where i ignored all these symptoms for
you know
eight months nine months just ignored it
didn't go up it checked properly and
then and in the end of course i could
have done it sooner
and then i went in
and they went in with a wire and a
camera let's have a look how badly it
was blocked you know the afternoon they
had a so open heart surgeon there and
the guy puts a stent in like a plumber
and they were going to decide whether
they could get a stent in and open up
the artery or they were going to go and
do a hot you know bypass basically and
take a bit of rain and stitch it in
and then i came out and i felt like 10
men yeah really yeah yeah amazing
amazing went out my bike it's like i
gained 50 watts it was really yeah
brilliant and then i haven't um
i haven't had any paint since and i
still i did six and a half hours day
before yesterday with the lights over
so
yeah yeah yeah
speaking of progress then one of the
things that i we were kind of talking
about before we um we started chatting
but also i i really wanted to ask you
about kind of the last point i was
really curious about regarding the team
was that your philosophy towards the
team
is evolving with time and how you get
the best out of the people um people are
typically quite rigid in their
philosophy in the way they think but i
read that you're now taking a individual
first approach
not a team first approach is that
accurate and why
well i think there's the individual kind
of performer right you know and i think
everybody's so i don't think he's
individualized in terms you know the
team still is still absolutely you know
the fundamental kind of attendance of
what we do
but
there is an individual behind the
performer and that's worth exploring and
maybe being expressing more
we've been tremendously successful and
and with team sky we had a a brilliant
run and
and won
you know also a lot of back to back uh
tour fancies and other grand tours
however over that time you know there's
like you know you can you just when you
become serial winners
uh it becomes predictable
and of course some people like that if
you're a supporter some people don't
like that it becomes predictable and you
know the interest and the sort of the
emotional response that it generates the
performance generates is an interesting
thing to contemplate you know we just
seen the formula one
at the weekend and everybody's gripped
by it because it was just unpredictable
nobody's gonna happen there was suspense
there was an emotional you know
roller coaster
along with the actual performance
and i think when you look at sports if
you look at you know if you think you
can perform
on the on a vertical axis performance
goes up and up and up and up and up
until you become serial winners but then
across the bottom you think actually
what kind of emotional response what
kind of feelings what kind of style what
do you know what how are you making
people feel and you can have a team like
german let's say
who's just serial winners and thinking
people go yeah okay but the germans love
it obviously but obviously yeah okay but
a team like who achieved the same like
brazil people love brazil
everybody loves brazil why is that what
what's the difference you know they're
still performing they're still winning
so the metric if you like the winning is
still similar but the way that they're
going about winning seems to be slightly
different
and senna let's say the motorizing
scenario or schumacher maybe or you know
some other
and you think i don't know you saying
bolt or maybe the all blacks or just
united manchester united time yeah
injury time yeah and there are certain
teams or that i think i uh um don't
really want that not feeling that but
this one over there doing the same thing
i love them and what is it about what is
it about those teams and is that
something
you can is it just happens or is it
something that you can actually work
towards so
for example when i when i first went
left home to go to france to to be a
professional cyclist there was something
in that sport
that chimed with me so much and got me
so passionate that i left everything
behind i left home i went to a foreign
country i couldn't speak the language
didn't know what i was going to do but i
still did it i still went because
something was pulling me so it's not and
there was something about that sport at
that time that i just adored
and when i think now and think right
when i was that age
what kind of team
if you'd have told me then at that age i
could be running one of the world's
biggest cycling teams
and had the success that we've had and
still be running one i think what kind
of team would i have loved to have seen
what kind of flair and what kind of you
know how would they erase that would
have been you know would have been very
much part of the bus
or would it been like you know just
bulldoze your way through what would it
be a bit of panache and flare and
yeah yeah exactly exactly and so can you
just where does style
you know and that sort of emotion fit
in terms of performance and you can go
after performance clinically you know
and can style ever be a performance
attribute and if you think about that
you know so so is that something you can
go after or is it something that you
just have is it just something that
happens in the chemistry of a team or is
is it the way that you are so for us we
obviously race the bikes but what about
off the bike and the way you speak and
the way you do your social media and the
way you are with people and the way you
are with fans and who you are the colors
and everything else that goes on
is there something in there
which actually can bring out the
individual and you get to know the
individual so they're not just kind of
guys with sunglasses on with
helmets on and kind of like sort of
faceless you know warriors as it were
where's the person you know we've got
guys from ecuador and you know come from
you know
unbelievable backgrounds in ecuador and
their stories of how they found
themselves in our team is just
incredible
and the guys from columbia and the guys
from britain the guys from everywhere
they've all got their journeys they've
all got personalities they've all got
the humans you know they're interesting
the back stories are interesting
and it's like where does that all kind
of come together in a team and how does
that get how do you how do you watch
that performance and see all of that is
it possible
and i'm really interested in that in a
minute this is such a
this is such a conversation that someone
who has won
a lot
would have they're now thinking about
the way they want to win and it's
interesting because when you were saying
that i was thinking about different
teams and jose mourinho and klopp and
and then the one that i really stumbled
on was boxing mm-hmm where you can have
a
vladimir klitschko yeah who holds the
the throne for
a decade but then everybody turns off
the sport yeah and then you get an
anthony joshua and a tyson fury that
come again they're still champions but
they're doing it in a way that's
captivating the public so my my question
in my mind then became well you have to
ask yourself is the objective just to
win
or is it to win and make loads of money
and inspire a generation because
people are flooding into boxing now
because of fury and aj and the money
those guys are making is way more than
klitschko was making yeah so i guess
it's the case i think it's like the old
is that
we've been talking about it you know
it's like
if if you win a lot you could be
respected you'll be respected but can it
be respected and loved
can it be respected for your victories
but loved for a way that you achieve
them and that's where the that's the
holy grail why is why is being loved why
does that matter
admired and love don't get passion from
people and you know just generate
emotion and that's what sports about you
know that that's what really i think in
the end you know it's there's something
about sports which is inspiring it can
move people
you know and and i think the whole
emotion of sport is something that's
it's why we love it in the end you know
you can take part in it i can watch it
you know why was everybody watching the
41 on the weekend because it was so
inspiring and emotional it's just wow
you've got to see it and the same with
klitschko or
tyson fury you know when he's got that
knockout punch
and he's out
and then he gets back up again that's
insane
it's just insane i can feel myself now
it's just like
that's
those moments in sports are what sports
all about
and i think that's what you know
if you're involved in sport and you like
a you know been most of my life in
baldness but of course you've got to try
and win first and foremost and winning
itself isn't easy you know and then of
course that's got to be the the first
kind of absolutely you're not going to
you'd never go off to style if it wasn't
intelligent
but some people have got intelligence
and style and the flair and the cantonas
or the centers or there'll be race you
know
and i guess i guess for me i know this
sounds
maybe a bit bonkers but you know we're
in the business of thoroughbreds really
if you think about it the top of the top
where i'm you know the guys that work
with that they're all thoroughbreds
but i want a thoroughbred racer
somebody can race art sport isn't a team
sport it's a race you know we're racing
one another you're trying to outwit your
opponents and trying to maneuver and
it's not just a physical endeavor it's a
race
and there's something about
you know there's something very very
um cool
about the guy the great races
and there's something about that which i
just adore you know you saw the weekend
with hamilton and the stop and what i
mean unbelievable don't believe i could
i admire those guys so much i really do
and and i think um
i think most people admire hamilton now
maybe even a little bit more because
we've seen a different dimension of his
character a different kind of he was he
was amazing after that in that in that
short period after that you know when
when verstappen won the way he managed
himself and the way he handles himself
was just
unbelievable and i think everybody saw a
different
a different view or looked at lewis
hamilton through a different lens and
they saw a very different person than
what they would normally maybe see
and therein lies the magic of sports i
think you know
my last question for you again i asked
this question from a very personal
personally curious space because it's a
problem i've not figured out for myself
which is we talked a little bit about
sacrifice there is about romantic
relationships
and the struggle of being
a great and winning and sacrificing and
doing 200 days a year at races while
also trying to
meet these goals of romantic
relationships i've struggled with it
pretty much my whole life
um
have you struggled with it do you have
any answers for me
no i don't know
i'm not your money
unfortunately no that's something that
you know i wouldn't say that um
i'm not good at if i'm honest if i'm
really honest you know
and
i think i'd like to be you selfish do
you think
sort of selfish yeah probably or or um
yeah sort of concerned really you know
like so so like driven a god i can't i
can't
fail at this you know and that that sort
of
fear of and it is there's something that
inside of me that that worries about
failing so much
that i i can't switch off from it in a
way you know
in 2014 you struggled with that right
when
that was the you didn't win the tour de
france big time yeah yeah yeah what do
you mean by big time give me the
specifics i don't know i just i just at
the time i was embarrassed and not not
about the
the the team or anything i just for
myself and i felt this think of what god
i couldn't go out couldn't got a house
couldn't leave the garden
i remember speaking i i called steve
peters from the garden and thought god
i've let everybody down i've failed and
it was it was a yeah quite quite
winning for me doesn't actually that
sounds terrible but
i mean i get exhilaration from the
moment that you win obviously it's great
to win
but the emotion the degree you know the
depth or the amount of emotion it gives
me to
to win is is nowhere near the amount of
motion i get from
losing so the negative emotion from
losing is
massive for me
whereas the positive of winning is he's
okay yeah it's done the job part of the
journey great fantastic let's keep on
going
and so i think this kind of the
not avoidance but not wanting to lose
and really trying to help people to win
you know it's like do you know where
that comes from because that does sound
no i don't know intense
yeah i don't know but i've always had it
always been the same you know i get
super excited by wanting to do some big
bold ambitious things and then going out
and saying right we're going to let's go
and do x and then afterwards i think oh
wow
what have i done and then of course then
i've got to make it happen and i get
after making it happen and and i think
that's where i've got this kind of
dichotomy really of there's part of me
which is my probably my heart
which is the
crazy ambition of wanting to do things
that's never been done before and
helping people go after stuff and all
that kind of you know nothing's
impossible nothing's impossible anybody
says impossible we'll prove you wrong
and then you've got to get after it
and i think the getting after is where i
go back into more of this whole the
detail of martial that's the doing of it
and it's as if my head and my heart sort
of sets these
wild kind of ambitions and then i got
and they've got to switch out of that
into the right let's get after it and
then not wanting to
not succeed of whatever it was drives me
then you know
we have a tradition on this podcast
which is the previous guest writes a
question for the next guest and i don't
actually get to see it until i open this
book so okay
you will also be writing a a question
for my next guest
if you could turn back the clock on one
day this year and do it differently what
would it be and why
this year wow
there's a lot going on for me this year
that's for sure
i think i'd like to go back so milly's
just had her 17th birthday
and um
on the 29th of november
driving
car tests etc
and
i wouldn't go back and change it
necessarily but i just go back and
relive it because i love that then
rather than something i'd change i'd
just go back and do it again
yeah it's like a big deal you know get
your car and
yeah so i'd like to come spend that
whole day again
that's what i'd like to do
amazing well thank you so much for
coming here because as i said to you you
know it's so funny that i've i've never
met you but you've had such a big
influence on me and my philosophy and
helping me articulate that and um you
know sophie who's my assistant once upon
a time worked with you and she yeah he's
always spoken well
about you which is actually really
remarkable because people often don't
leave a job and speak so highly of the
person they worked with but even you
know since we started doing this podcast
she was telling me you've got to get
you've got to get one you've got to get
dave on um and she's she's always just
sung your praises and
um your philosophy the way you
articulate it i think it's helped more
people than you'll probably ever realize
but it's an i consider this to be a huge
honor having you here today um as did my
friends when i told them you were coming
and that's for very very good reason
because everybody thinks you're a bit of
a legend so thank you so much for your
honesty thank you thank you and thank
you for what you guys do you know thank
you i think you'll bring a lot of
happiness and joy and inspiration to a
lot of people
people listen what you got to say you
know which is which is remarkable and i
think um
and i think you've
you know when you've got when you get
that there's a sense of responsibility
in a way isn't there by the time you
know by the the level of
the platform that you built for yourself
and you do an amazing job with it so
thank you oh thank you means a lot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]